[Music]
there are a bunch of celebrities who
know exactly what life could be like for
Beyonce's twins he's wanted a free ride
over here actually scarlet is three
minutes older than her brother Hunter
who went on to become a political
organizer in 2008 though he was named
one of People magazine's sexiest single
men Gisele Bundchen sister Patti is
younger by five minutes she started
modeling at the same time as Gisele at
age 13 but it was Gisele
catwalk career that took off while Patti
developed other talents to the best chef
she's like this fight she's the best in
desserts my dreams she makes all the
desserts she should be like a Bochy
Stewart and did you know that Ashton
Kutcher has a twin Michael he's an
advocate for cerebral palsy awareness
it's not an obstacle he was diagnosed as
a child and says Ashton was always a
devoted brother he's my twin and he's
you know he's always gonna be my best
friends it's a bond that you just LLL
never be broken
Keifer Sutherlands sister rachel younger
by seven minutes opted to go behind the
scenes as a TV post production
supervisor Alanis Morisette and her twin
Wade are both musicians he's an indie
rocker of course rockers Joel and Benji
Madden are well known twins
[Music]
Joe is younger by five minutes but the
poster children for growing up as twins
under the limelight are these two Ashley
and mary-kate Olsen is it fun to have a
twin sister Juana how come because it
give it took Olympics have that and one
favorite game but make a big surprise
do you like to put makeup on warm turned
into a billion-dollar business but here
is one more celebrity you probably
didn't know as a twin Vin Diesel
yep The Fast and Furious star showed off
his twin to the world when he posted
this shot of his two favorite poles that
is Vin's twin all Vincent on the right
posing with the late Paul Walker
[Music]
you